Based on the Chinese legend that already inspired a beloved animated feature
comes.
Disney's all new re-imagining of premium VOD pricing strategies to service,
an evolving consumer dynamic new law.
And remember,
move on the girl who used her wits and determination to grow strong and save an
empire. Forget her and beat this natural born killer killer.
Who's just waiting for an excuse to kick something sharp through your chest.
Yeah.
Oh, and while we're at it,
you may as well forget all those songs you loved and your first animated crush
and the funniest Disney psychic since the genie. Oh man. No.
Musu if any film need as many Murphy to lighten the mood, it's this one. Okay.
Get out. Get let's get this show on the road.
C prepare for an absolute feast for the senses full of
vibrant colors and sumptuous landscapes.
That will be totally wasted on your crappy TV.
As you soak in locations from the beautiful forest of New Zealand to some of the
most stunning regions of China,
ignore that in this gorgeously rendered cinematic experience that continues the
live action Disney tradition of being a cliff notes version of a story.
You already know
[inaudible] up for the big fireworks finale. Oh, they cut that too.
That's a shame follow Milan on as she goes undercover in
the world of men.
You're a good man.
Which as all men know is a world of grab,
cuddling and sniffing each other's necks.
What you guys don't sniff your bros to pay fine more next for me.
Oh yeah. Where this time the entire cast is refreshingly Asian,
including the exact opposite of Harvey Fierstein.
My women buxom.
As we watch Mulan struggle against the constraints of a sexist empire
until she lives.
Her truth rises like a Phoenix and fights to preserve the same empire
that oppressed her.
Sort of thing with women in any way, penalty, that.
Then becomes an official tool of that oppression.
Join our greatest decorated wards and the emperor is gone.
Hashtag girl boss prepare for two hours of people talking about their cheese.
The chief of base the universe and all living things,
but she's powerful watching cheap, cheap, cheap, cheap,
cheap it's over 9,000.
Well Milan crosses swords with this Inigo Montoya want to be in honor of my
life.
Yes.
Well you will die. And this awesome bird lady
whose unique perspective on the nexus of power and womanhood is way too nuanced
to survive the movie. But Hey, this is a war film at its heart.
People are going to die and most of them thanks to move on.
[Inaudible].
So saddle up with Disney's latest live action remake that tries to be a fantasy
Kung Fu movie, a war, Epic,
a fun kit's wig and an ODA female empowerment yet doesn't explore any one of
those lanes deeply enough to be satisfying, but Hey,
at least it went over well in China, right? Wasn't that the point I'll come on,
Disney. How did he get out? Pandered by Michael Bay.
Now this is a master at work.
We got to call the central government for help.
Story main NA shell. That's what I call music,
sword art offline. Chuck curious,
Nick Schmidt and Winston Falcon punch.
You either die a hero or you live long enough to see yourself become the villain
two lawns. Hmm. Yes.
A tiny net is a desert ends and a gender reveal party.
[Inaudible].
The emperor's new dude.
Only one of the four riders in this was a man.
And I'm bet it was his idea for muon to let her hair down before a fight,
the buns are strategic. Dude. Do you know your moose shoes from your zoos?
Then you should play our Disney edition of the fandom by the trivia game where
you can win up to $650. Click the box or the link in the description.
Get in loser. We're going shopping.
I'm crazy enough to take on Batman, but the IRS. No, thank you.